oh well we'll try to avoid looking at
that that's just sort of there so that
we can we're talking to you
we're talking to you we're not talking
to the monitor we're talking to you to
you welcome back to the production blogs
it is production blog 7 maybe I can't
remember yes yes yeah oh seven survived
the holiday season it is a new year
feels good yeah oh happy new year
yeah 2016 the year of something uh I'm
so stressed out I am so stressed out
like everything's coming together but
I'm so stressed out and I was having
nightmares last night and I I am
probably going to have nightmare like
production nightmares yeah I'm gonna
have production nightmares like probably
all week because next week is shoot day
January 14th Arab Hill is going to have
its production yeah this is our last
full week pre-production and then and
then it's production and then it's
post-production tan post but so we've
got crew almost locked in we have cast
locked in we have equipment locked in we
have camera locked in
we have location locked in just some
peripheral stuff that we have to kind of
put together swords swords yeah still
still working on the swords there will
be swords we guarantee you guys it's
it's volume that's the that's the issue
yes we had to fill a whole wall that's a
lot of sorts a lot of swords but 80% of
what you just said we accomplished in
the last five hours yeah
pretty intense getting gear locked down
Game of Thrones is in town and shooting
and has devoured most of our gear or has
devoured a lot of gear not most of our
gear has devoured a lot of gear in
we're fighting game of Thrones guys
fighting Game of Thrones planted to the
Apes is also in town
yes sort of sort of in town but they've
they've taken our dolly grip yep so we
have to replace replace Steph miss you
Steph yeah but I mean value eyes yeah
you know Planet of the Apes is up here
and we're down here but cool wise and
and this is sort of the this is one of
the lessons that we've been kind of kind
of laying I mean we knew it but this I
think is a valuable lesson to to share
is that one of the hardest parts about
filmmaking like indie filmmaking is
getting people to just return your calls
yes because you think you think that
it's like okay well yeah if you're a
zero budget you know nobody just [ __ ]
around like people aren't gonna take you
seriously but then the moment you've got
money right some kind like all of a
sudden doors open and to a degree yes
like certainly we've gotten a lot
farther off of ten thousand then we
would get off of zero but there's still
a lot of stuff where it's like it's hard
just to get people to even pick up the
phone and call you back after you leave
a message because your your $10,000
budget yeah is is less than some of
these other productions are spending on
catering yeah you know that I mean and
location was a particularly tricky one
that we ran into because you know we
were looking at various spaces but the
kinds of like the other productions that
come in like they'll roll in and just
offhandedly block off three four weeks
right because it's like and they're like
for a three four five days shoot because
they just need the flexibility to come
in like anywhere between this date and
this date and so they're just like oh
well screw it like they have the cash to
just lock off an entire month so if
you're a production that's sitting there
going like okay we need two days to just
be in and out and like you're you're
dealing with a very precise two days
like yeah you're a paying customer but
they would need what like 15 of us 12 to
15 a match yeah productions that size so
it's it's always kind of in their
interest to like kind of hold back and
fish around for something for something
bigger and that goes for a lot of things
in the chain it goes for locations it
goes for like big-ticket equipment you
know cameras dollies anything that
requires sort of a lot of infrastructure
and it has a high day rate because
$10,000 it does let us sort of tap into
some cool stuff sure but then you got to
convince those cool stuff the people who
have that cool stuff to take you
seriously and that's been that's been a
challenge and that's a challenge pretty
much all the way up like as long as your
budget is under I'd say six figures like
you're in Canada because once you once
you're over six figures you're a fairly
large production as far as Canada is
concerned yeah
so yeah like you know once you're over
that though I mean people start bending
over backwards for you well well I think
the other thing too is like okay we're
talking Game of Thrones Game of Thrones
they're probably having a be unit shoot
oh it's going DUP unit and we did a
rough calculation of how much the
probably paying to have the studio space
booked it is probably around $40,000
just to have the location issue yes like
their daily budget is our entire budget
right no like no problem in fact we were
estimating that one element of that
budget like a particular sort of stunt
ish element or especially a specialty
element special hire is probably in and
of itself $10,000 a day right right
to upwards of like 20 mm-hm per day and
the reality is is that we're trying to
stretch $10,000 for absolutely
everything yeah and as it speaks right
now we have $14 flex flex dollars mics
and then and then it starts chipping out
of out of post-production yeah
which you know which is unfortunate but
you know and I mean that's the thing is
it's $14 flex where I put in a few
contingency things like one yeah our
truck we're hoping is only gonna cost us
about $250 but I have allocated 350 in
there in case we have to drive around a
lot more than we planned
but we might drive more than we planned
and go over 350 in which case we would
have to pull from the post
yeah but post already has a decent
amount of contingency built into it for
for a variety of stuff huh but oh the
other thing that we didn't talk about in
detail was that we have now four members
of our cast oh yeah
instead of one so when we did auditions
back in early December no no means
December we just saw some really good
performances inspiring inspiring and Dan
decided that human I mean
collaborative we said this would be
pretty cool if we could fill the space
with more than just one person and we
did some you know rearranging in the
budget and now we have four yep which is
pretty awesome
because I think it's gonna give a new
level of dramatics to it it'll change
the aesthetic of the room and the video
portrait but I think they'll get the
point across to a little bit more you
know one of the really challenging sort
of things is is that when you think
about it the logistical overhead between
us and Game of Thrones really isn't all
that different no I think it's just pure
scale yeah it's still the same amount of
like cognitive overhead yeah
Oh totally I mean our catering is gonna
be me and my mom running out to Costco
and then running home and making some
crock pot recipes but in fact that
actually that's a great point their
cognitive overhead for catering is
probably lower because if they just call
up a caterer and are like just here's
the day ya show up with food yeah
invoice the office yeah well and then
even to like those caterers sometimes
they just roll up in a big truck yeah
here here's
if if you're shooting something like
catering is probably one of the most
important things because that is going
to have an immediate and dramatic impact
on crew morale on crew energy and you
know the passion and focus that they put
into their work and we've talked about
this before investing in gear versus
investing in people then you know you
people are going to give you huge
returns and just like the the example on
ours is we've got this really kind of
this this is complicated or at least
challenging we have this challenging
camera move that's part of it and if
your crew like if your dolly grip is
focused and alert and and their hurts
into it yeah then they're gonna be able
to nail it and you're only gonna need to
do you know four or five before you've
got what you need and at that point it's
like hey we've still got two hours left
in the space we've still got two hours
left on everybody's everybody's time
clock let's let's now do some variations
and you can get a lot of you can get
options or hey you can just pack and
everybody go home yeah that's you I mean
we know you know but especially if
you're you know on a on a set where
you've been volunteering or you've been
brought on as a volunteer I think it's
super important that if you're in you
know if you're in the lead of that
production feed your volunteers well
because they have no real connection to
the project I mean people can be really
excited about whatever it is they're
doing
but give them something okay so that's
that's that's enough rambling so this
will be this will be our last production
vlog before production like since we
since everything basically starts
rolling Tuesday afternoon we're just
we're not gonna do one next weekend but
we they will so I guess we'll see you on
set totally high five high five